what's going on with how many reboots
and remakes are happening at the moment
is it just that it's too much of a risk
to try and start a new franchise
I think it's
on paper doing a reboot or a remake of
something uh is it should be a winning
strategy because you should in theory
have instant access to that devoted fan
base who just want to see their favorite
property brought back
excuse me
uh and so financially it seems to make
sense the the problem is that you can't
often capture lightning in a bottle you
know it something like Ghostbusters
classic movie we all loved it back in
the day uh it worked because you know a
bunch of really good creative talents
all came together had a great script a
great director everything just worked
perfectly
you know they tried to do it for the
second one back in the 90s uh yeah it
wasn't very good uh and then you got
Ghostbusters 2016. well we all know how
that turned out
we're gonna we're gonna reboot it for
modern audiences uh capitalizing on the
Ghostbusters name and look what happened
it was a flop you know but it happens
over and over again but it's like
they're always trying to uh recapture
that lightning in a bottle from these
These past successes because
um well movies are expensive to make now
particularly if you're dropping 200
million dollars on a film damn man
that's a lot of money to invest you want
a pretty solid guarantee that it's going
to be successful and it used to be that
that was
you know that was a pretty good way of
doing it you know you can Market it as
we're gonna we're gonna bring back this
great franchise that we've got a huge
fan base for everyone will be happy
did you see that clip of Matt Damon on
first we feast or the hot hot wings
where he's talking about why modern
movies seem to be less adventurous have
you seen this clip do you know what I'm
talking about I I have yeah because it's
like he's uh he's crying while eating
this stuff
I don't know if this is like the
environment yeah I don't know if this is
almost like how you inject people with
like you know truth serum and stuff like
their mind is so fogged by the pain of
the the hot wings that like they're just
gonna spit out straight on truths um I'm
trying to remember what exactly he said
during that he says that the death of
DVD sales has meant that movie studios
can't be as venturous anymore that you
basically got a second bite at the end
of being able to make money it might not
win at the box office but it can kind of
be this ascending underground Victory uh
and he uses this example of someone that
said it's gonna cost me uh 25 million
for this half of it goes to this I need
to double the spend on that so I need
100 million to make the money back and
the only way I'm gonna do that is
through DVD sales what's your thoughts
on that yeah that's very true
um it was very much the long tail of
sales that would come after the
theatrical release and uh yeah there's
been plenty of movies that um you know
they didn't make their budget uh when
they were in movie theaters but they
ultimately became profitable years later
just through DVD sales and all that
stuff
um so yeah there's absolutely something
to be said for that
um
yeah it's it's I guess it's just a
different world you know
um with
streaming obviously that's radically
altered the equation
um you know the moment something gets
released onto streaming it's going to be
on on the high seas and that's going to
take a huge chunk of your Revenue as
well and people just getting it for free
um and yeah I guess there there's just
this general climate of risk aversion
you know what is the things that makes
money at the moment
um the other thing I was going to say is
the the death of the sort of mid-budget
movie they don't really exist anymore
you know there used to be a time when
you would get
your big you know Blockbusters it was
like 100 million dollar budget uh you
would get your little Indie movies that
were done for practically nothing but
then you would get in between films that
had like 20 30 million allocated to them
not a huge amount but then they don't
have to make a huge amount in order to
become profitable so I think that's been
a big change as well
one thing that I definitely hadn't
considered was that Harvey Weinstein
might have been the gateway drug or the
pebble at the top of the Avalanche that
caused Downstream from this for a bunch
of other problems to occur I understood
that it is not particularly
popular at the moment to uphold men
particularly white men as being
competent in in the media
I didn't realize that this would be this
sort of pincer movement two-pronged
attack both coming from the internal
milieu that's happening inside of the
studios in the production World
generally and then also being fed back
up from what's happening in society as
well that's quite interesting
I think as well like we now are past the
time when writers in Hollywood actually
lived lives you know if you went back to
the the 70s and 80s uh in Hollywood the
these writers man most of them had lived
a life like they might have fought in
Vietnam or something uh they they
probably came from rough upbringings
they had to fight their way to get into
Hollywood and uh you know probably just
had interesting life experience that
they could bring forward to their their
writing on screen
um the writers that you get now
they would go into some
um you know
so that is that sound is I'm currently
in Austin Texas
and there's been a freeze storm
overnight which means that every tree
has got water on it which then freezes
and then the trees snap so I may go
outside of here and find that there's a
tree that's Fallen but the roof seems to
be okay at the moment so we will we will
continue damn all right we'll keep going
well as long as as long as you're alive
we'll keep going all right
um yeah so the writer's night like their
career path is basically uh either
um mummy or daddy is already in the
industry and so I get straight in or I
go to some liberal arts college where
I'm taught to hate you know white people
and and men and stuff for four years
um then get into Hollywood I say all the
right things uh about down with the
patriarchy and stuff and I just get
hired and so
um I don't have any life experience I've
never faced adversity I've never had to
struggle for anything in my entire life
and uh I don't know how to bring that
forward into my characters and so the
the things I know how to write about are
you're awesome the way you are because
you've already succeeded because I've
succeeded from from doing very little uh
and that's that's how they that's how
they rationalize life
um and so again
you know it all feeds into this this
culture I guess that we have now in
Hollywood of narcissism of selfishness
of
um you know
I'm the most important thing in the
world and I'm perfect uh and you know
it's not about improving yourself
anymore it's not about taking on
challenges it's just about everyone else
accepting you for what you are right now
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]